The joe rogan experience.
You were on Fox News.
Yeah.
It was once upon a time.
Made it in there.
Did it smell like sulfur smell like souls?
Why are the girls that work there so fucking hot?
Cause I know how to hire people.
This insane.
They're way too hot.
It's not fair because men will agree with them just to hope that they will say
Yan high five you'll change your whole philosophy.
And there's,
you can find clips on youtube where people have just put together every time
they like open their legs during the various segments.
Praise the Lord.
They're too hot.
It's unfair.
That's like hypnosis.
You know some of those.
What was that woman's Nagin?
What's her name?
The really angry wagon.
Kelly.
She's so fucking hot.
It's ridiculous.
Where she showed me some Meghan Kelly.
This is,
oh this is,
this is really cool.
Play this because this is how I found out about Lee,
but back it up.
So I'm sure you guys are gonna have a lot more jokes for the rest of the
campaign here.
They just keep going.
And can I,
can I just ask a question?
Sure.
What?
What is Fox News?
It's just a parade of propaganda and it,
it's just that it's just a festival of ignorance.
What people are dead and Iraq.
Come on.
This is ridiculous.
What's the point of this?
Wow.
This is insane.
Go outside and go,
well,
fuck.
Love your face.
Really.
You know?
Can you get all the news,
all the news?
You can.
All right.
Thanks.
As the best watch.
This is the best part.
We're also texting out captain Kirk this morning because it's Saturday morning.
Some fun.
Greg,
you got the cushiest job in the world.
Yeah.
Look who?
Just a beam.
The board right now,
the ladies from the Star Ship Enterprise.
Hello,
welcome
call.
I just wrote a new book on Captain Kirk and the way he was able to woo beautiful
women like this.
It's all coming up to the table.
Talk about Captain Cook,
getting laid,
but come on the fictional character captain car too,
by the way.
Not even William Shatner.
Yeah,
no,
no.
All Book I was in the green room with.
Then I could not figure out why there were these women there.
I had no idea that you just,
it was almost like it was scripted because you said that and they showed you was
the most inane stupid piece of shit.
I didn't even know that was coming up next.
Oh my God.
It was perfect.
You couldn't have been,
what if they went to some series news and fuck you.
You know he wanted to,
you could see in his face as he read the teleprompter.
He was like,
all right,
we're going to get out of this and go,
ah shit.
Indeed.
It's like completely proved your point.
Like right away,
like,
come on man.
How did Kirk get laid?
He gets give written.
They wrote did.
He got laid.
The writers made them get laid.
He's not a real guy.
Jesus fucking Christ aliens.
There's two wars going on.
The fucking tire banking system had to be bailed out by taxpayer's money and
they just wanted to see what a human cock was like.
That's how he got laid.
Do you think they have like a bunch of shit that they will throw out there like
beach balls to distract and they get like they get it from the CIA every week.
[inaudible] Star Trek check.
They just have to send it like this.
The way we want you to talk about this week,
like really just to Zap the American mind.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
You know what I mean?
I don't believe that it is.
I don't believe,
I think I tend to think that it's more in competence than Dan and his conspiracy
ratings.
They don't actually care about the news.
They only care about ratings.
They don't care about the news,
but I think in general,
like even the most of what we think of as being this big gigantic conspiracy
with our government and the media is more in competence and Horesh behavior than
anything just to prostitutes.
They prostituted themselves out because that's the way they got the good
assignments.
They got to the good places.
They've got the big ratings.
I mean,
you don't get to that point.
You don't get to that job unless you've proved yourself a faithful foot soldier
to whatever their messages generally,
you know they're not,
you're not going to get hired on there.
Yeah.
And even guys that used to be kind of like rebels,
like Geraldo Rivera for other Rivera was kind of a rebel at one point.
Dad,
you know,
he was the guy that had Dick Gregory on TV and showed the Zapruder film for the
first time.
I had a fistfight at a KKK rally,
I think on a shelf.
Someone hit him in the head with a chair.
They might not even been trying to hit him.
It was just a melee and I think a chairman flying and he got his nose broken and
he was fucked up.
But that he was so excited,
so excited,
yet an actual cut on his face.
I'm a tough guy.
Like,
what's that?
He was supposed to box frank Stallone or something crazy like that too.
How long time ago?
I'm like,
God,
they might have actually done it.
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure,
but he's a wild dude,
or at least he was a wild dude.
You know,
and now he's just like Fox News puppet.
It's weird when you see the ones that actually stick to their guns.
They don't last long.
I mean Cenk Yoga lasted two months at Msnbc before he went,
before he needed to leave.
Amber Lyon is another one that left because her Bahrain story actually he
mentioned by rain,
uh,
CNN,
she brought it back to them and said,
this is what's going on about rain.
But they were doing ads talking about how great Bahrain was and they wouldn't
play her segment.
Yeah,
yeah.
She,
she's been on the podcast before and she explained it all to us and it's,
it's so hard to believe that what we consider to be like shining revered
institution of news,
like CNN,
it was just a bullshit propaganda wing that they,
that they're capable of that kind of behavior.
If she's telling the truth.
I don't know.
I wasn't there.
I assume she is.
She seems very honest.
I don't know anybody else's side on the other side.
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck is really going on.
So I probably shouldn't comment on what CNN did or didn't do,
but I know for a fact they're not reporting a lot of shit that's going on and
now we're putting a lot of shit.
And I feel like all of these networks,
that mainstream media,
it's a very small box of accepted thought that is allowed on them.
It's not,
it's not,
they're not going to go either fairly far to aid to either side or outside that
box.
No,
it's not really the news.
And that's one of the more interesting things about the internet is because of
the Internet now there's all these sources that are like more real news.
Like they're telling you about shit that's going on that you might not have
known.
So we get Anal Fox News girls,
why they're so hot it,
those girls are so God damn hot.
Like I don't want to marry them.
I don't want to have relationships with them.
But if I was a single man,
I would be very attracted to those angry bitches
or the weathermen in La.
I just think there's,
so,
there's so like aggressive,
I dunno if they're so strong,
like there's so stern in their opinion.
Yeah.
Most of them are not dumb.
There's nothing to do with dumb.
No.
It says about those mean bitches.
Yeah.
Just because I'm a glutton for punishment.
But if you,
um,
like when you're on that show,
like what,
what,
what does it like when you were in that studio,
does it feel weird?
Do you feel like,
well that's the thing.
It's like all of them just seem like they're doing their job.
I mean,
yeah,
they went for the evil empire,
but they don't,
they're just like whatever gets them through the day.
Oh I need to say this thing and this thing.
And then where we know we wrap for the day.
Like,
so I had to remind myself why it was important for me to do that.
I like read,
read an article about how a million people died in Iraq.
I mean this was,
this was several years back and uh,
and you know,
cause you don't want to fuck up the show.
Like I felt like I needed to do it and I only want it to be on there once.
I was like,
if they're having me on,
it's going to be a one time thing.
This is yet
dude.
It was if you were like a publicity whore and I know you're not,
but that be an awesome move.
I mean it worked out
great.
I never thought it was 7:00 AM on a Saturday.
I truly thought the only people,
and this is four or five years ago,
we're not,
everything on the news went online.
Right.
I truly thought the only people seeing it would fox news fans at 7:00 AM on a
Saturday and instead it went up online and viral and all that shit.
Man,
if you got something relevant to say the Internet,
we'll catch it.
Yeah,
they'll find it and they'll put it out there to go back to that girl like
standing,
sitting there with her legs open.
This is insane.
I just want to point something out of how we are so weird like as a culture that
this is a part of like normal everyday office life.
Like,
we've got to make some decisions here.
okay,
look at this woman.
She's showing everything but her vagina.
I mean her knee is just strategically blocking her.
Lavia.
Her legs are wide open and she's hot as fuck.
Now,
here's the thing.
If you put the Kyron right in front of the vagina,
then everybody would know the news.
Exactly.
We'd be a very informed country
and women would get angry at you if you knew the news.
Oh,
you were looking at her vagina and you read the fucking news.
Huh?
Like she like,
it's just weird that they get to dress like that.
Like she's completely wearing come fuck me.
Pumps could back that up again.
Let's,
let's dissect this.
Look at her like her shoes.
Those are like,
I want to go out and get sexy shoes.
There's a not comfortable by any stretch of the imagination.
They show most of your foot.
You,
her,
almost her entire legs are exposed.
Me.
Imagine if a guy was sitting there like that.
Do you know how bizarre that would be if there was a show where a guy was
sitting there in a tiny,
tiny kilt and you know that you could bear if he moves his left knee an inch to
the right,
you're going to see his cock for sure.
And they also have like an ejection button that slings them into the
stratosphere once they hit 35 hit an age limit.
Aw,
poor girls.
That's sad.
It's actually has some kind of irritation down there.
So,
well I think Sarah Pailin brought the dumb milf back so maybe uh,
maybe will move in that direction,
but I don't think she actually brought it back.
She brought it back for a little bit.
But now Pete pro like cotton,
you say too much crazy shit.
Guelph,
if we're getting the grandma right,
right.
She's guilt.
You don't want to say that though.
Cause that'll fuck with you.
Dig.
It's creepy.
Yeah.
MILF is okay,
but Guelph not so much.
It's just weird that we have these odd standards of,
of sexual attire in the workplace and not just in the workplace,
but on television,
like on television.
Promoting this to strange propaganda machine and just really hot girls with
their vaginas,
hanging out explosions and hot girls.
Okay,
I can't pay attention.
Whatever the fuck.
She said,
well,
she's here.
Oh my God.
See if I see that girl.
I go,
wow,
I wish she liked me.
You know?
Especially if you're lonely and you know you're not married or anything.
Did that like 12 times her size?
Yeah,
it's rob Ford's fat brother.
And what other shows have like Kimbera man that from the ground that isn't,
no,
it's totally an upstairs.
They're panning from the vagina up.
It's off center just slightly.
He's trying to show off his two though.
You gotta give him credit.
He's,
well,
you know,
he's got to go to war.
You know,
you gotta get her respect.
He doesn't give a fuck look like the only way I'm gonna get this one is if I let
her know I don't give a fuck because my gut,
I'm not trying to cover myself up.
I'm staying an extra straight.
I'm spreading my legs.
Why?
Look at that package.
He's going for the don't give a fuck.
He's like,
I'm,
I might be a fat fuck,
but I'll fuck the shit outta you.
Dirty Bitch.
I'm fat because I like to live the good life.
That's what he's saying.
Like others play lists,
all the different ones.
Was that one the one that you just showed?
That's a Fox.
Went to the redhead.
Yeah,
it's great.
That one,
the blonde that was on the screen.
I know who she is.
That's the one.
She's been on these things before.
They're all hot though.
They're beautiful.
It's weird,
but it's just such dirty trick.
I'm not,
especially like if you're married and you know when you're trying to be
monogamous,
you're going to look at sex in a different way because you look at like a girl
that's like super,
super hot and you go,
oh,
I could never get that.
If you're single,
if you're delusional,
you'd be like,
man,
if I just ran into her at the right place time,
maybe this could happen.
So it's a different thing.
So it's the,
there's a wistful,
almost romantic way.
You look at the Fox News girls,
if you're married on the same note,
it's like when a,
when a,
when a hot celebrity like gets divorced,
there's something inside the most loser of guys.
It's like now I got a shot,
like Angelina Jolie gets to a voice and people are like,
okay,
they think all I gotta do,
he there,
I'm just there guys are so fucking delusional.
They feel like all they gotta do is be at the right place the right time.
You know,
maybe she goes to the car shop cause her wipers broken and she wants to try to
fix it herself.
And you know,
I get to impress her by my knowledge of windshield wipers and she realized I'm
just a regular guy and sometimes girls,
Jesus Christ,
she actually pulls her skirt up.
Look Bam.
Like,
oh,
how dare you,
you dirty bitch.
Oh my God.
Past she sits right.
Ah,
it just seems like a perfect posture.
It's kind of like going back to when you were like really young looking at like,
like JC Penny's lingerie catalogs and you wonder why people that Watch Fox News
are idiots.
I mean,
not that a lot of network time,
but you know,
they did that study that people that watch Fox News,
no less about what's happening in the world.
The people are watching no news at all.
I believe that.
I love that.
Yeah.
Does that make sense?
It'd be no,
you gonna you gonna find out about Captain Kirk's love life.
So these are two regular guys.
ABC.
Look how,
let me see as regular gals,
ABC is more probably geared towards women that don't want to be threatened
drunk doing the background.
He's never seen this video and know there's the naked no,
it's just hammered.
Any shorts.
Well Christy,
they are the whole neighborhood knows the boy.
They
fucking second story window and fell in the bath.
That's amazing.
Oh my God.
That's funny.
Yeah.
If you leave the fucking camera on long enough,
people catch the craziest shit ever.
Did you see any of the like the snow storm,
uh,
driving footage son you got jacked?
Yes.
Yeah.
It was a snow storms all throughout the,
uh,
the country.
They've been getting these nutty snow and ice storms.
Okay.
Yeah.
What is that man?
It's,
it should be not,
it's unfair.
I mean,
I don't want to say that pretty girl shouldn't be able to get a job.
They certainly should,
but it shouldn't be exclusively pretty girls telling you about important shit.
We of course were too week.
We're not paying attention to the message.
No,
not at all.
But that's thing.
Have you seen an ugly girl on the news?
You're like,
Dad,
girl knows his shit.
Right?
She fought her way to the top.
There's something about,
um,
like,
uh,
like what I said,
like those Fox News women that like the one you were talking about before the
show started,
who argued with someone about Santa Claus being white.
Megan Kelly apparently as it said very authoritatively that Santa Claus is
white.
Yeah,
she's very authoritative.
Always.
A lot of those gals are.
But there's something like four Beta men,
especially for men that are weak and beaten down by life.
The ultimate fantasy is that this woman accepts you the ultimate fantasies that
she's impressed by you.
An exception cause she's so hard ass.
She's so obviously beautiful,
but also so hard ass that there's this,
there's this,
uh,
you know,
when she's around you,
you want to like mock Obamacare.
You want to just start making fun of it.
It like he'll write specific job roles.
Yeah.
Just to get in and has to get in and just talk to her.
San Is White.
You're God damn right.
He is white VRC.
Show me one picture with Santa with black.
It wasn't drawn by a black guy.
Yeah.